you have all been so good to me over the
years I love you from heartfelt speeches
to viral moments et is taking a look at
the highlights from the 2019 People's
Choice Awards leg shot to the icon when
Stefani and Blake Shelton turned the
PCAs into a super cute date night
it's incredible to have a best friend
like that guy he's the singer even gave
her man a special shout-out when she was
honored with the fashion icon award I
love you Blake Shelton your babe from
date night to a family affair pink hit
the red carpet with her husband and two
kids and blessed beyond belief because I
can bring my kid with me the singer was
also crowned this year's people's
champion
it feels powerful to help stop fighting
each other and help each other get
together with your friends and change
just a great friend with those smile and
blue eyes and for sure my wife's
favorite human on the planet same adam
sandler same the actor presented the
peoples icon award to his friend and
co-star Jennifer Aniston the actress
dedicated the honor to her friends
co-stars but if I have any claim to this
this word icon it's only because I was
able to be on a on an iconic show with
yes with the iconic cast and and an
iconic haircut yes ye-es yes and we're
still waiting on that friend's project
Jen there's a lot of different ideas but
who knows let me tell you another queen
that stole the show
zendaya who took home two of the night's
biggest Awards still young and coming up
and I and I just appreciate the love and
the support the actress landed the
trophy for drama TV star of the year for
her work on HBO's hit series euphoria
I'm so lucky to be working with the
people that I'm working with I'm so
thankful and female movie star for her
role as MJ in spider-man far from home
I'm a part of it I mean I've been
watching you for like a while now it's
kind of obvious following a near fatal
car crash in September Kevin Hart made
his first public appearance at the PCAs
first and foremost man thank God because
I definitely don't have to be here being
that I am that makes me appreciate life
even more and check this out David Spade
went viral after giving this look to
Noah sent in a Oh totally meme worthy
[Music]